well in the states right this doesn't
apply like in most other okay but we're
not we're in the UK even in the UK women
don't naturally that's not good
that's not true um even I don't
necessarily know what it is for divorce
but from I've heard a lot of like I get
DMS from people constantly and I've
gotten horror stories from Men in the UK
and I I do Street interviews horror
stories of Child Support so it's it's no
different and it's you're in the west
we're not talking about global if I have
to give up my career for you to build
something and then you cheat on me and
we have to get divorced big man give me
my money
because you feel like a ways but that's
how the courts see it the courts see it
as it's fair for a woman to get this
like we were saying about the West the
reason that this is a law is because the
courts have decided not women that it's
fair for women especially where they
couldn't maybe have an income
no but the context is the court
men pay
and then women claim legal aid which is
taxpayers money which men are the
taxpayers because they're working right
then what happens is is basically women
get half of the man's money because he's
working he has to pay the legal fees he
has to pay child support which also goes
to the woman and then there's a level of
entitlement that women think that
they're entitled to it why your children
his children are entitled to it because
they're the children but you as a woman
are not yeah and again coming back real
quick coming back to even the cultural
differences me myself in my faith when
you get married the woman has a dowry
and that's the only thing she's entitled
to when she's married to the man he pays
for her upkeep and her life of what she
had so if she started off as a
Millionaire's daughter he needs to
provide that lifestyle if she started
off as on ten dollars a month that's the
minimum he has to offer when they get
divorced she's not entitled to any of
his money or assets while she's working
in the marriage she's her money is her
money his money is very money if that
makes sense when they now divorce she
doesn't take any of his manual assets
and if they have children he has to pay
responsibility for his children and his
assets get divided to his children
nothing to her so naturally I come from
a thing where we have like a prenup
let's say because a woman can't marry as
a gold digger this country this or these
Concepts have come from where courts
have decided it's fair for women to get
this much because when they're left
they're left with nothing yeah but it's
called business because men pay into
listen have you ever been to call have
you ever actually had to pay if you
realize the amount that people feel like
oh sorry the amount that people have to
pay for example with children there's a
lot of money that goes into the court
system isn't a recent this is a recent
law this wasn't around 200 years ago
what the men and women dividing their
assets when they divorce
there's also nothing stopping women from
working today so exactly so but the
courts do take that into consideration
I'll put it like this when women say
they're a single mother yeah they're
they're not a single mother they're a
Wim they're a woman with children yeah
and then they become available if they
want to right if a man is if a man wants
to look after his kids and you are
separated you're not a single mother
she's a single woman yeah yeah she's a
single woman's but in the court she'll
say I'm a single mother I need the money
for to look after the kids blah blah
blah all right
and she has control of how the money is
spent so she can spend it and she's
actually she won't and she's
incentivized to not let the man see the
kids like she's literally paid too
because she gets more child support if
if the father doesn't see the kids yeah
and I think that's toxic women who put
themselves before their children no yeah
but again A woman has to look at herself
and say what if like you said it's about
her children from then if she then
thinks about herself that's her as a
woman okay well I can flip it back to
the earlier conversation when we were
saying about the whole dynamic that we
were talking about where it was
and that comes into play because the
woman is not thinking about the children
she's thinking about herself how she
feels at that given time
based no no real but based on looking
through the phone getting angry all
these feelings what's happened the
projections that have happened lack of
no emotional management and then when
you're in no no no when you're in the
courthouse remember you have to provide
evidence at in court for why you want to
see your children right if a woman says
this is I don't want my partner or ex to
see my kids because it's abusive he's
toxic he sent me these messages on
social media he did this this and this
and screenshots with were given to the
court she can put in an injunction
without that just that evidence alone
now that man has to pay to get the
injunctions removed prove his innocence
then pay to see his kids and pay pay for
his children even though he's not seeing
them okay so then he's financially
drained okay I feel like there's a lot
of responsibility taking off the man
cheating for example a man who's married
and has children he should understand if
I cheat I'm going to break my home they
should not it's a responsibility on
himself
we could say it's wrong but he shouldn't
lose how I'm not saying [ __ ] I'm not
saying that I'm saying if a woman now
goes on his phone and she's now looking
she shouldn't find anything right she
shouldn't because he should also adhere
to his own responsibility and not do
anything right no no but why was she
looking because she suspects this she
suspects because he might be doing
something yeah that's selfish man hold
up hold up when you say something you
already know the answer
cheating is selfish a man cheating but
also breaking up that home is selfish is
that but so he also needs to understand
his actions are going to break the home
what action is more heavy yeah your man
cheating or the fact that a woman
destroys her home for her children what
act is more heavy in a marriage respect
should still be there whether you like
your wife or not you should respect her
if you're going to Stephanie can you
answer his questions yeah what did you
answer what what has more weight in it
yeah a man stepping out just busting a
nut or you breaking up a home where your
kids will suffer the results but you've
just you've what is more heavy what's
more heavy you as a man could have
created what is more heavy the man so
the man cheating yeah okay
okay okay this right there modern women
selfish I swear to God I swear to god
stop it stop it stop it stop it you're
over talking me on my own show that's
rude uh like this is this is this is the
epitome modern women selfish because you
think because he did something to you
that is that is more heavy than you
doing something to your children no I'm
not saying that I didn't say that this
is this is
okay okay you've talked a lot today okay
I've given you a lot of my time and I'm
saying like that like I actually forgot
what I was gonna say
what I'm saying is the man especially
when he has children he needs to
understand the repercussions is the
woman's going to be hurt she might not
get over it he's breaking up his family
home he's putting his selfish needs
ahead of his child no no no he's not
she's very breaking up the home like
this is like like women do something and
we still put the accountability on men
you broke up the home
you chose to leave okay I think we're
not understanding a man stepping up with
transparency is very different to a man
going behind her back and causing her if
he said to her let me finish sorry if he
said to her do you know what babe I'm I
need to sexually as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible